hello freak [ __ ] I got to ask you
guys this before you take off
did you see this Trump thing the CNN
thing yeah they're going after the kid
who made the meme heard it wasn't a kid
well this is the thing Jamie I'll
explain the whole thing but it was a kid
that they went after who had made a
video or made a meme but apparently the
meme came from a video and the video was
made by someone else other than this kid
and they they're essentially they
threatened to dock this kid
they said they reserve the right to
expose him and I heard he's 15 I don't
know if that's been 100% proven I don't
know if it's been 100% disproven but I
just heard that that is a lie was it a
lie the 15 year old mess of this kid
well I don't know if that's the case
because he's not actually 15 words
because now they're talking about a
different person the original video I
haven't heard internet we made a video
your file those Trump body-slamming the
C&L they're saying that that's Facebook
true this is what it is Trump was on the
WWE and he did a thing no I am the guy
to the ground and so they're going to
they took that and put a CNN head over
the person's body who Trump slammed to
the ground and then Trump tweeted it was
very very offensive very inappropriate
very non presidential pretty [ __ ]
funny oh my gosh the president is
nothing compared to him talking about
that woman having plastic surgery saying
that her face was bleeding badly from
the facelift that's just gross
like that is like it's only something
wrong with him that's so beneath anybody
yeah that's not just beneath like the
president that's beneath anybody reading
it there's something deeply wrong with
him he's getting worse he's going off
these Keys on Twitter right now pressure
probably getting mentally ill at this
point because and even qualities
it isn't mental illness like your brain
chemistry changing and can you imagine
what would by the way when the alt were
alright came after me for the show I had
this other realization which is even
people you don't respect if enough
people hate you it it's it's got a
effect on your brain and imagine being
Donald Trump where
half the world or more is like [ __ ] you
all day every more than half the world
it's a imagine a large number of people
maybe help of America but exactly but
it's way more than half of America now
there's a large number of people in the
Republican Party that are criticizing
you it makes me mad is that we called it
the women's March and that no one really
gives it respect for what it was because
it was the largest protest in the in our
history of our lives was to an anti
basically an anti-trump protesters
elected and like we should just be
talking about that more like that's
never happened in our lifetimes or our
parents lifetimes right there was that
big of a protest because someone was
being elected and it just kind of gets
like pushed to the side I mean I'm glad
I called the women's yeah March but she
thinks that basically that we the idea
of it was marginalized and the scope was
marginalized because they called
themselves a woman smart maybe I don't
know because it's such a huge deal like
I mean it was so exciting to be a part
of that you saw those pictures and they
weren't just in every city in America
they were in every city in the world
that's how opposed we were that didn't
happen when you know anyone who in our
lifetimes know we've never seen this
kind of a reaction to a president before
not rare but we wanted to talk about the
CNN that's what's crazy is that CNN is
becoming a monster to fight a monster
right and they're threatening to DOX
people that are making funnies memes i
all that was was funny i mean nobody
really thought that donald trump was
actually slamming the person that is CNN
that doesn't even have a head that as a
CNN for a head and all anis healing some
reporter from CNN was going after the
person they tracked the person down on
reddit who made the memes who gives a
[ __ ] who made the memes that's crazy by
the way the mean itself isn't offensive
at all help it's funny the offensive
part if anything is that the President
of the United States thought it was
appropriate to retweet it it's more dumb
than it is offend me even slightly I saw
him that he retweeted over here that's
my reaction listen you are correct in my
opinion that the the CNN in particular
and the press in general is as filled
with warts
not as filled with warts but he's filled
with warts in the same way that there is
on dick
[Applause]
no joke to make re Joe that was the
right dog way and the right time I
didn't didn't mean it and it is affected
are they are there
the top right there we would had such a
laugh over we got to sand them off
before I see the missus but it's not
that it's this this new realm that we're
in where these cable networks are
struggling so hard to get attention and
they're focusing on really crazy [ __ ]
like CNN had a bunch of people fired for
making up fake stories about Russia and
Trump or not substantiating these
stories and making sure they're correct
before they released it and put it live
and so three people had the rosanna
things three but the CNN's not
struggling that's what they are they're
struggling they're down 20% in ratings I
thought CNN and MSNBC and some other
left-leaning thing although I don't
really consider CNN left-leaning is like
at the top of the charts now and what I
read and might be [ __ ] I don't know
well let's pull this up see if you can
find out what I read was that CNN is
down 20% since June and that Fox is
actually up 20% no no so logical effect
typed in CNN ratings it says chump is
way off on CNN's ratings being down and
okay I want to that found no no I didn't
I didn't hear it from Trump and I heard
it from someone else was probably
parroting Trump yeah I mean we're all
that's that this therein lies the
problem we're all being racked filled
with misinformation from both sides and
each side is so ideologically in their
in their echo chamber that they all
accept the left and the right included
all except the information that they're
getting as gospel truths that cannot be
assailed by the other side's facts and
so nobody neva knows what the truth is
anymore
nobody that knows what the argument is I
think if they read it it's true
oh so Fox News CNN MSNBC so Trump is
responsible for everybody paying
attention now driven by surges for the
Rachel Maddow Show last word with
lawrence O'Donnell no idea who that is
MSNBC is up a whopping eighty six
percent in local view total viewers Wow
in primetime that's amazing you watch
do you watch Rachel Maddow no actually I
think she's great I think it used to be
she's just no good
you know Tucker Carlson he's a
well-dressed guy with a great haircut
and a good vibe oh you know what he is
though what he is is like this
bridge between regional people and
right-wing maniac yeah he's a pretty
reasonable people for sure there's a
Hannity Sean Hannity so much more
reasonable than John is a dick though
that's the problem okay he's an he's an
[ __ ] to the people he interviews his
whole thing is that he bombards them
with like kind of snide interviewing
that they relentless snide interviewing
you know they make of a deserve it like
he bring time senado postures people
Jeff because he knows that they're going
to say something stupid is a sign he can
mock exactly what
[Applause]
[Music]